oh do I have something exciting inside
this box let's open it up and check it
out spoiler alert it's a new Sony full
friend camera I'm so excited
[Music]
oh my gosh they sent the white one look
at this it's so light most of the Sony
zv line is geared more towards vloggers
and beginners this is by far the best
beginner camera that I could ever have
wished to have had when I first started
making YouTube videos this right here is
a full frame camera and most of these
run for a pretty hefty price tag so now
that we have a full frame affordable
Sony camera game over
[Music]
here
so this camera I would kind of put in
the lineup between the Sony a7s III and
the Sony fx3 now there are some
similarities but there's also some
differences why you would choose the
higher end cameras over this one but
honestly for most people who are just
coming into this starting content
creation the past week that I've been
using this camera I am so blown away by
the footage even just going outside
vlogging that if this was swapped with
one of my Sony a7s3s I am not even sure
if I would notice when I'm looking at
the footage using the camera I
definitely would notice first of all
because this is the white version so it
has a completely different look even the
buttons and some of the layout of things
even the interface on the screen it has
a completely different feel than a bunch
of the other cameras in the Sony Alpha
lineup so you can get this with just the
body or the kit lens so this is a 28 to
60 lens and surprising lens is actually
a pretty decent lens for how much Zoom
you can get obviously one of the reasons
that you would be getting this type of
camera is be able to swap out lenses so
the fact that you're able to just pop
this off add another lens will
completely change the look and feel of
your video why I really like this lens
is if you are just using this for
vlogging this is so small it's super
Compact and even the camera body itself
is super light this does have a flip out
screen just like so watch this wait this
is great look
there we go so this just rotates very
similar to the a7s III and I also like
that it does flip this way so I can see
myself when I'm recording so Sony has so
many different lines of cameras and in
their zv line which is geared more
towards vloggers and content creators
and people kind of on the go it has a
recording button up here at the top but
it also has a light that you'll see in
the front and this is also something
that I absolutely love is on the front
of the display you can see that there is
a red ring all the way around the
display hi Nathan hey hello and that
will let you know that you're recording
if you're filming this way and there
have been so many times when I'm filming
and I actually don't realize that I
didn't hit record so this will alleviate
all of that the thoughtfulness that they
put into this kind of a camera for newer
content creators is something that I
really love oh man I'm so excited to be
testing out this new camera right now
I'm actually in Telluride I've never
been here before we're going to dinner
and we're in the little town and today
we snowboarded all day and I actually am
very impressed I mean I fell a lot but
the amount that I fell the first time
that I did this was exponential so we
were making progress but this little
town is so cute
[Music]
the best part about having a cool frame
sensor is because the sensor is larger
once it gets dark out that's going to
allow so much more light into the sensor
so we'll be able to get lower light
photos and videos so one of the reasons
that I think a lot of people would
choose this camera over the a7s III or
the fx3 is obviously cost because this
is a much less expensive device and this
does have some really fun AI features
and some of these higher end cameras
don't have but some of the things that I
feel like aren't really that big of a
deal for some content creators is you
can only use SD cards with this whereas
the fx3 and the Sony a7s3 you can use CF
Express cards which are much faster and
will allow you to record higher quality
media so this can shoot up to 60 frames
422 10 bit which is equivalent to pretty
much what you can film with the Sony a7s
III the big difference though is with
recording time so you won't be able to
record as long as you could with the
Sony a7s3 you're basically getting a
high-end full-frame camera in a smaller
compact lighter size with AI settings
with a few features missing that most
people probably really wouldn't even
notice so some of the fun features I
feel like for a lot of newer content
creators is the fact that it's taking
into account that you may not actually
know how to use a camera in all of the
settings and I totally get that because
there are some settings even on my
cameras now where I'm like hold on a
second how do I do this how do I do that
well the great thing about this is it
will do a lot of these things for you
you don't have to actually do any
adjustments for example it has this
thing called Product showcase this is so
great for me because obviously I'm
always showcasing a product but this
will allow you to have a fast focus of
something that you're holding alright so
I'm going to turn product showcase on
when I hold up an item
it focuses on it so fast
this looks like I'm holding up an Oreo
but
it's actually just the lens cap product
showcase
[Music]
product showcase an unboxer's dream so
now we're going to test out the
background defocus now this is a shot
that I feel like a lot of people love to
get I'm such a huge fan of having kind
of that beautiful blurred out bokeh you
can get that by adjusting the aperture
but honestly if I told someone that who
just got this camera they're like I
don't even know what that means which I
mean I feel like you probably kind of
should maybe look it up but with this
you don't really have to you just hit
background defocus it automatically will
adjust the aperture to give you that
look and you don't even have to know
anything it hurts my soul but also like
that's freaking great so right now the
background defocus is on so the
background should be blurred out you
can't really see what's going on I
really love that bokeh look that you can
get with a lens when you're turning the
aperture all the way up but with this it
does it automatically so you don't even
need to mess with any settings so now
we're going to turn it off and it'll
show you what it looks like without it
so here's what it looks like with the
background defocus off there are a lot
of factors that go into this depending
upon the type of lens you have what the
aperture actually is and this is is a
4.5 so this isn't really going to give
you that much g-focus but yeah this is
what it looks like
this other feature that I really like is
it has a cineblog feature so when I
click on this this changes a bunch of
settings it turns it into cinetone
footage and it also makes it widescreen
and 24 frames a second then when you go
in this gives you some different types
of flavors of cinetone so this is auto
color correcting your footage to give
you a really cool look the first thing
that we're testing out here is the
Sydney Vlog and this is with nothing on
this is off off off off next one will be
on
so here we are in cinevlog it is now on
and this has a more cropped look because
it does do the wide screen and I was
already shooting in 24 frames a second
but this will automatically take it down
to 24. and we don't have any looks on
yet so no little added flavors so this
is what it looks like just normal cine
tone no added color effects so let's add
the first one shall we
so this is the gold variation of the
cine tone check it out how does it look
shining shimmering gold and Splendid
this is cinetone ocean how does it look
does it look like I'm swimming under the
sea It's Always Greener and somebody
else's lake here's City tone forest does
it look like I'm out in the forest
hunting and Gathering planting foraging
for mushrooms there are so many color
variations now in addition to cinetone
is this this is clean now within the
clean there's other variations that you
can do of this as well this is clean
auto but you can also change this to
Gold ocean and Forest you can also
adjust the levels of intensity high
medium or low but we're just gonna go
through the basic ones so you guys can
see this is clean what do we have coming
up next here we have Chic up next how
does it look I don't know the best part
about shooting these types of videos is
kind of going back and watching the
footage so like I'm enjoying it at the
same time as you guys are while I'm
editing it so here it is Chic next up we
have have fresh how fresh does this look
do I look like Super Fresh like the
produce out at Whole Foods I don't know
hard to say
here's fresh and next we have mono so
this is a nice black and white and this
doesn't have the option of giving you a
gold Ocean or Forest because obviously
it's it's black and white so this is
this is what you get it does have the
low medium and high settings though so
if you do want to add a little more you
could do that as well but here it is
these are all the color looks that you
have for the Cinematic Vlog options
there's so many options in here I'm
overwhelmed like I'm basically only
going to be able to scratch the surface
of what this camera can do in this video
it's just a quick little overview but
man wow there's so many things
foreign
[Music]
cameras is because the sensor is much
larger so this will allow you to get
more light so this is so much better for
low light videos and photography and the
other thing of course that I love about
these types of cameras is you can use
full-frame lenses now this is a new lens
from Sony and this is the 20 to 70 and
I'm absolutely obsessed now this lens is
an F4 so a lot of the G Master lenses
are like a 2.8 or a 1.8 so even though
this isn't F4 the fact that this is so
small and compact the fact that I can
get 20 to 70 inside of here is awesome
let's swap our lenses real quick
now I love this lens is this is much
higher quality glass than this one but
because this is a 20 this makes it
almost like the ultimate vlogging lens
now because this is a 20 millimeter
that's going to give you a much wider
field of view when you're vlogging so
here we go I am vlogging now there's a
couple options for studying your footage
now right now I have all of the steady
options off so this is just completely
handheld nothing special this right here
is in standard which I usually use and
you can see that there is a full frame
here and when I switch to get this
footage a little bit more steady that's
when it crops in slightly to help with
the stabilization and here it is a
little bit of a crop this is active
steady so I love putting this on because
it gives you a much smoother kind of
Vlog style cinematic feel and here we
are look at that super smooth super
steady gotta love it now we have one
more setting in here which is dynamic
active so this is super super steady but
it does crop in a little bit more so
there you see we are cropped in
but it's also very very steady super
stable
and I mean obviously like I'm just
holding this here but when I'm walking
around and being able to get smooth
steady shots of scenery or whatever it
is that you're filming that's when I
would definitely be using this this also
has something that is very unique it has
like an AI Auto framing option now this
is really interesting so as you can see
here I'm not really moving around but
the camera is actually moving a bunch
and you'll see I'm staying in the center
of the frame so this is like you would
give to someone who maybe doesn't even
know how to use a camera and they can
keep you in the center of the frame
because it does all the work for you and
it seems like the magic of this is It's
cropping in significantly so it's giving
the camera a lot of space to move around
to keep you in the center and it just
knows like it just knows that you should
be in the middle of the frame I'm I'm so
impressed another fun AI feature in this
is with the microphone it has microphone
directivity now I have a microphone that
I used to use by deity and it was really
cool because it had a front and back
microphone and you could choose to use
both the front and the back and each one
would kind of record on a separate track
or you could decide to use the front or
the back well what's cool about this is
if you turn it on auto it will
automatically detect where the
microphone should be pointing so say I'm
out filming some scenery or just filming
something and I'm talking about whatever
it is that I'm looking at the microphone
will automatically detect that I'm
behind and that's where the microphone
should be directed but say I'm over here
oh Nathan is now in the frame It's Gonna
Know to switch the microphone to him uh
hello hello the microphone is now
listening to me and my voice saying the
ABCs A B C D E F G but you can also
manually decide where you want to have
the microphone so it doesn't switch so
if you know you're out filming and you
only want it to be focusing on you I'm
going to switch it to the rear so now it
should only be focusing on my voice hi
Nathan hello hi can you still hear me
camera can you hear me hello camera
ABCDEFG like I'm sure I can hear you but
you can probably hear me better okay so
now this is me talking so this is what
it sounds like for me behind the camera
hey how's it going hey friends hey hi
hello yep now we're gonna switch it to
all directions so this is front back all
around hi Nathan now we're talking the
same tone of voice and
um I'm excited about Mario Kart so now
here I am filming myself so if you're
back there talking I'm still talking
about Mario Kart over here yep so the
microphone setting is definitely very
interesting and I'm super hyped to take
this camera out vlogging that's so light
love it the other thing that I like
about this is it does have an XLR hot
shoe so when you do take off your little
microphone hat your microphone wig
windscreen whatever you want to call it
this does give you access to this now
you can use any of the Sony XLR hot shoe
compatible devices microphones we've got
plenty now with the XLR hot shoe why
this is so great is you don't have any
other cables you can just plug in a
microphone and there you go
automatically have a microphone that's
attached and the camera will recognize
it now if you don't have one of these
microphones and you have one that
actually has a 3.5 millimeter input like
so that's okay because we do have a 3.5
millimeter microphone inputs we also
have headphone monitoring a micro HDMI
output USBC and that is where our SD
card is now this is a Sony XLR input
that I use all the time this is
basically what I've been using for years
for audio input now why like this is
because it does have two XLR puts so I'm
able to use this Sennheiser AVX wireless
system and if I want to have an
additional shotgun mic I can plug that
in as well fully kitted out it
definitely adds a little bit of weight
but honestly
considering the alternative I'm into it
I really love this AI feature it will
recognize when two people are in the
frame and auto adjust the aperture so
that both are in Focus you'll see in
this demo the aperture is automatically
starting to change as Nathan comes into
the frame so you'll see I'm still in
Focus he was out of focus and then he
slowly starts coming into Focus super
cool I think he did it okay go see okay
we'll see go see
oh
so cool yeah if I would have had this
when I first started vlogging I don't
even know another thing this has is a
self-timer so you can set a timer for
three seconds five seconds or 10 seconds
and you can have this be repeated or
only once so right now I'm just gonna do
it once so I'm gonna do three seconds
and I'm gonna flip that around
hi hello so something else that is cool
on this that I really love is they have
an snq setting and I'm not gonna lie for
the longest time I didn't actually
realize what that stood for it stands
for slow and quick this will give you a
really quick way to be able to jump into
slow-mo videos or time lapses I did
actually shoot a little time lapse here
in Colorado when I was in Telluride and
I love shooting time lapses and the fact
that this was so simple and easy to do
made the time lapse just like that easy
so you can shoot 60 frames a second and
you could do up to 4K 120 and HD 240.
those will actually be coming out later
at launch so I can't actually test those
out right now but it is pretty cool that
if you do want to shoot slow-mo videos
up to 240 you can actually do that on
here well thank you guys for watching
I'll put a link in the description if
you want to check out this camera and
get more information because there is
honestly so much more that I didn't get
a chance to cover this is such a
powerful camera for the price that
honestly I'm I'm shook I'm just
everything about it every time I jump
into the menu and just test it out more
I'm more and more impressed so I look
forward to seeing what you guys think of
it and I would love to hear from you
guys what do you think about all of this
AI powered videography photos all of
this stuff that is now being powered by
AI I'm kind of into it but it's also
really scary because what is even real
anymore I don't even know do I care do
you care I don't know I'm so conflicted
but I'm not conflicted in the fact that
I really love this camera and this lens
see you guys in the next video don't
forget to like comment and subscribe hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos because I will be posting a bunch
here shortly I've been filming a bunch
of fun stuff for you guys so I will see
you there and I think that's it okay bye
foreign